hey youtubers is Charlie huge news so
Marvel just confirmed that they're
working on a Punisher spin-off series
for Netflix it'd be just like daredevil
Jessica Jones based on Jon Bernthal
character yeah it's awesome news but
it's not that big of a surprise if you
remember there were rumors that this was
happening last year after they had
finished shooting a bunch of Jon
Bernthal Punisher scenes they said that
Netflix was just like so blown away by
his performance that they were like can
we do a series with him let's get this
going now but the problem in Hollywood
is that even though people in business
suits the control money get really
excited about things it doesn't mean
that it's automatically turning into a
series that we're gonna see episodes
from so really like a couple of hoops
have to be jumped through they have to
hire director they have to hire writers
so they're all working on that stuff
right now they just announced that
they're working on those things if you
don't remember the thing that was really
making people crazy last year was the
idea that they were so excited about
doing a Punisher spin-off series that
they had just sidelined their Iron Fist
series so like you know all the Danny
Rand fans are just screaming in the
background like how dare you Jeff Loeb
Joe Quesada but you know a bunch of big
people involved with the Iron Fist
project we're like no no no we are still
totally working on Iron Fist
it's just that I think that that project
is in such an early stage of development
that they don't want to announce
anything about it yet because usually
like if they have stuff to announce
they'll totally announce it they'll be
like oh hey you know we cast these
characters we have this director we have
these writers working on it probably the
best example that was when they
announced the Punisher for daredevil
season 2 they're like yeah we're totally
doing The Punisher it's gonna be awesome
cut to now yeah it's totally awesome
we're gonna give him his own series
that's how awesome it is I know you guys
are all probably wondering what's going
on with defenders especially because
it's happening around the time infinity
war is happening does this mean that the
Punisher is going to be part of the
defenders I'm assuming not the Punisher
is like one of those characters who's
just so crazy that nobody wants to team
up with him so I think what they might
do is they'll just use the Punisher in
the defenders Netflix series but he's
not gonna be super best friends with
everybody he's just gonna be getting his
punisher swerve on while the defenders
get their swerve on next big question if
they're already doing Iron Fist they're
already doing defenders when is this
Punisher series going to come because
there's going to be a daredevil season 3
we might see Jessica Jones season 2
after defenders there's a big question
about timing because we know Luke Cage
is coming then they have to do iron fist
then they have to do defender so there's
a certain pecking order for
these serious drop in the showrunner for
Jessica Jones said that because there's
a contractual obligation that these
characters have to be in a defender
series by a certain time it was causing
her problems trying to do it Jessica
Jones season 2 so the time frame for
defenders is coming so quickly that they
don't have time for Jessica Jones season
2 that I'm guessing that we're not gonna
see a Punisher spin-off series before
the defenders team-up I'm guessing
they'll probably just push it to right
after Punisher shows up in defenders
does some crazy [ __ ] that has
ramifications that spin him off into his
own series the thing that's different
about Punisher and for most of these
other Netflix characters are that we're
already going to know all about we're
already gonna see him for the first time
in someone else's series it's kind of
like Luke Cage and Jessica Jones they
kind of set the Luke Cage character up
during Jessica Jones even though he was
only a minor part of it under normal
circumstances when you ask the Netflix
people and the marvel people like hey
you know can characters show up in other
characters storylines are they gonna
reference each other's storylines
usually they say after they get their
introduction like after they have that
first series they tie up their storyline
then you start to see characters
crossover I should actually probably say
just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen Jessica Jones yeah I'm just gonna
reference some specific story beats from
that especially from the end so even at
the end of Jessica Jones we only get
references to daredevil like we haven't
even seen him show up next to her
on-screen yet
that is really like the level of
crossover at this initial phase right
now once we get two defenders once we
get closer to that you'll probably start
seeing characters crossover in a much
much bigger way so until we get some
different information this is my
understanding of the Netflix timeline we
have daredevil season 2 coming then in
the fall we'll have Luke Cage then that
next spring we'll have iron fist and
then right after that we'll have
defenders I'm assuming defenders would
be like a summer 2017 thing it's
actually on IMDB for 2016 I think that
they're gonna push that by year but
remember the jessica jones showrunner
said that there is a ticking clock
there's a contractual obligation in a
time frame that they have to hit with
all those characters so I'm assuming
that it's gonna be 2017 so we get to
2017 we see defenders it's so amazing
everyone poops their pants and then we
move on to like the next series for all
these characters we get to daredevil
season 3 we get our Punisher season 1
but what is the storyline well largely
it'll probably build on what have
and defenders which remains to be seen
but it'll probably involve some Iron
Fist characters it'll probably involve
the hand the chase this bigger
supernatural war that they kind of
teased during daredevil with these hand
characters in Madame Gao but it's a
little too soon to tell and when we talk
about the Netflix characters we talk
about street-level heroes Punisher is
the most street-level of street-level
heroes I mean he literally walks around
street gunning people down meaning that
whatever storyline they choose to use
for him it'll be way more grounded
probably weigh less supernatural than
say like Iron Fist which does get into
some really mystical stuff will probably
wind up seeing a little bit from his
backstory now in the comics he went to
the Vietnam War because this is more
contemporary
it'll probably Afghanistan like he'll
probably be in Afghanistan vet what
about punisher max wouldn't that be an
awesome storyline to do the punisher
gets locked up in maximum-security
prison with all of the villains that
he's helped put away orange is the new
black punisher that would actually be a
really awesome series to see let me know
in the comments what punisher storyline
do you want to see them use for punisher
season one then you think that they
could do based on what's going on in
this Netflix universe so like don't
expect Doctor Strange Punisher you know
where he like merges his soul with
Doctor Strange and uses mystical bullets
stuff like that's probably wind up being
gritty crime drama so I feel like
Punisher max him getting locked up in
prison is the most realistic choice but
could also be really awesome because you
can lock him up with a bunch of C and D
level Marvel villains and he can just go
to town for 13 episodes the easy
crossover points to Punisher goes to
prison the other Netflix characters come
to visit him to get information on their
own cases like Jessica Jones is tracking
someone down the Punisher has info for
so she visits him in prison Matt Murdock
is prosecuting someone in court that he
knows Punisher has info on so he goes to
visit Punisher there's just there's so
many ways to crossover with a prison
setting the next thing you'll probably
hear about this Punisher series is when
they officially hire directors they hire
a writer and they start working on
stories then they'll start announcing
characters I'm not really expecting to
hear a whole lot from that at least
until next year most of their energy is
going to be spent promoting daredevil
season two because that's coming so
quickly if you guys don't know daredevil
season 2 is dropping the week before
Batman V Superman comes out so you'll be
able to watch all of daredevil then go
see Batman V Superman most of the videos
that I make for that like the episode
videos will be just like my Jessica
Jones videos so be sure to subscribe to
get everything if you're not not sure or
you haven't seen all my Jessica Jones
stuff I'll put a link for that in the
description I'm gonna have to start
ramping up and doing some more Punisher
videos but why guys wait for all that
you can click here for all my daredevil
season 2 videos it has like my master
Netflix playlist well the Netflix shows
and you can click here to learn all
about the Civil War special that's
coming next week thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you